NOW, CARLY FIORINA ISN'T THE
ONLY CANDIDATE WHOSE CAMPAIGN
SEEMS TO BE COLLAPSING.
JEB EXCLAMATION POINT -- WHO
PROBABLY NEEDS TO BECOME JEB
QUESTION MARK -- WAS ASKED "UNA
PREGUNTA MUY DIFICIL ON HOW HE
IS GOING TO GET BLACK PEOPLE TO
VOTE FOR HIM.
>> OUR MESSAGE IS ONE OF HOPE
AND ASPIRATION.
>> Larry: HOPE AND ASPIRATION!
OKAY.
NOT AS CATCHY AS HOPE AND
CHANGE.
BUT ASPIRATION, IRONICALLY, IS A
VERY POPULAR BLACK NAME.
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS.
TRUE.
(LAUGHTER)
YO, ASPIRATION!
YOU COMING?
I DON'T MAKE THIS UP.
ALL RIGHT, SO HE'S SORT OF ON
POINT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, HE CONTINUED
TO TALK.
>> OUR MESSAGE IS ONE OF HOPE
AND ASPIRATION.
IT ISN'T ONE OF DIVISION AND
"GET IN LINE AND WE'LL TAKE CARE
OF YOU WITH FREE STUFF."
>> Larry: WHAT?
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
BLACK PEOPLE VOTE SO THEY CAN
GET FREE STUFF?
THE ONLY TIME BLACK PEOPLE WOULD
HAVE VOTED FOR FREE STUFF WOULD
HAVE BEEN FOR ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
WHEN THE STUFF THEY WANTED TO BE
FREE WAS THEMSELVES.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THAT MAKES SENSE!
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
LOOK -- ALL RIGHT.
MAYBE HE MISSPOKE.
BUT HE GOT A CHANCE FOR A
DO-OVER WITH CHRIS WALLACE ON
HIS SUNDAY SHOW -- OR AS WE SAY
IN THE FAKE NEWS BUSINESS, A
"FOX MULLIGAN."
>> WE NEED TO MAKE OUR CASE TO
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS AND TO
ALL VOTERS THAT AN ASPIRATIONAL
MESSAGE FIXING A FEW BIG COMPLEX
THINGS WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO RISE
UP.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WANT.
THEY DON'T WANT FREE STUFF.
>> Larry: YOU JUST SAID IT
AGAIN!
WHAT IS THIS WEIRD
RACIST WORD ASSOCIATION THAT'S
GOING ON IN YOUR HEAD?
YOU HEAR "BLACK VOTERS" AND YOU
JUST THINK "FREE STUFF"?
IT'S LIKE HE'S PLAYING HEADS
UP -- HE HOLDS UP HIS PHONE,
SOMEBODY YELLS "BLACK VOTERS,"
AND HE GUESSES "FREE STUFF!"
(LAUGHTER)
ANYWAY, THIS GUY HAS A LOT OF
NERVE ACCUSING BLACK VOTERS OF
DEMANDING FREE STUFF WHEN THIS
COUNTRY WAS BUILT ON THE BACKS
OF FREE BLACK LABOR.
(APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT?
IF MEMORY SERVES, WHITE
SOUTHERNERS HAD QUITE AN
APPETITE FOR FREE STUFF, TOO.
BUT FORGET SLAVERY, OR DON'T.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION,
JEB EXCLAMATION POINT.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY YOU'RE OUT
OF TOUCH, BUT DO YOU THINK IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE A
HUGE COLOR BLINDSPOT?
TELL ME -- WHAT IS YOUR OPINION
ON RACISM IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ARE
INHERENTLY RACIST IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IN FACT, I THINK THAT WE HAVE A
PRETTY NOBLE TRADITION OF THE
OPPOSITE.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
>> Larry: NOBLE TRADITION OF
THE OPPOSITE?
THAT'S LIKE GETTING A POSITIVE
HERPES TEST BUT TELLING YOUR
GIRLFRIEND, "DON'T WORRY, BABY,
I HAVE A NOBLE TRADITION OF THE
OPPOSITE."
(LAUGHTER)
NO, YOU HAVE A NOBLE S.T.D., AND
YOU SHOULD REALLY GET SOME
VALTREX.
BUT THESE ARE ALL OFF THE CUFF
REMARKS.
AND THOSE CAN BE TAKEN OUT OF
CONTEXT.
SO WHAT ARE JEB BUSH'S THOUGHTS
ON RACE WHEN HE'S HAD A MINUTE
TO THINK ABOUT IT, TAKEN THE
TIME TO WRITE SOMETHING DOWN,
RE-READ IT, SENT IT TO A
PUBLISHER, DONE TWO ROUNDS OF
COPY-EDITING, THEN PUBLISHED IT
IN, SAY, A 1996 BOOK CALLED
"PROFILES IN CHARACTER"?
"SINCE THE 1960s, THE POLITICS
OF VICTIMIZATION HAS STEADILY
INTENSIFIED.
BEING A VICTIM GIVES RISE TO
CERTAIN ENTITLEMENTS, BENEFITS,
AND PREFERENCES IN SOCIETY...
MANY OF THE MODERN VICTIM
MOVEMENTS -- THE GAY RIGHTS
MOVEMENT, THE FEMINIST MOVEMENT,
THE BLACK EMPOWERMENT
MOVEMENT -- HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
GET PEOPLE TO VIEW THEMSELVES AS
PART OF A SMALLER GROUP
DESERVING OF SOMETHING FROM
SOCIETY ."
THIS IS NOT A GAFFE.
THIS IS HOW JEB BUSH REALLY
FEELS.
HE THINKS THE SYSTEMIC
OPPRESSION OF BLACK PEOPLE BY
WHITE AMERICA IS A "BLACK"
STRATEGY.
THAT IN THE 1950s, BLACK
PEOPLE HAD MEETINGS TO TRY TO BE
MORE VICTIM-Y --
LIKE "WE ARE NOT GETTING NEARLY
SEGREGATED ENOUGH OUT THERE!"
AND "HOW DO WE GET THE POLICE TO
BEAT US MORE?
WE NEED IDEAS, PEOPLE!
WHO SAID DOGS?
WATER HOSES!
VERY GOOD!
THIS IS HOW WE ENTER THE
1960s, PEOPLE!"
LOOK, I HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD
MY WHOLE LIFE.
MY PARENTS TOLD ME I HAD TO WORK
TWICE AS HARD FOR HALF AS MUCH.
THAT'S BEEN MY MENTALITY, AND
THAT IS THE MENTALITY FOR MANY
BLACK AMERICANS.
IT IS NOT THAT WE THINK OF
OURSELVES AS VICTIMS WHO DESERVE
YOUR HANDOUTS.
IT'S THAT WE KNOW WE HAVE TO
WORK OUR ASSES OFF TO OVERCOME A
SYSTEM THAT FOR DECADES HAS
INSTITUTIONALIZED WAYS TO KEEP
US OUT OF SOCIETY.
SO THE IDEA THAT BLACK PEOPLE
ARE STRATEGIZING TO GET ANYTHING
FOR FREE OUT OF THIS COUNTRY IS
INSULTING.
EXCLAMATION POINT.